there's something uncanny valley about
them right like I feel like I'm in Blade
Runner and one of them is definitely not
human
[Music]
I'm gonna say I'm not hip with the teens
I don't know what they're up to I see
him out there on Twitter yelling at each
other man when I was 16 I was a mess
oh yeah I don't know what that is
he's a Disney Channel Hector that looks
like a young John Mayer who is this
it looks like Justin Bieber's brother
may guests Bernardo Laura Jack is this
that Shawn boy this is Shawn boy this
like a cross between Shawn Mendes and
that guy from Twilight way that Shawn
Mendes no it's not
he sank to my baby right yeah he looks
different here
[Music]
oh I know this is I've seen her do
something somewhere she's that beautycon
so she's a makeup person I was I was
just watching something that she made
last week this is embarrassing
beautiful neutral Liza Koshi it should
be like things are just come down to
camera no I what's that she's a by ships
and find her
Eliza Kosh a youtuber great transitions
[Music]
it's a k-pop group right there probably
called something like totally now but
above the the cool-looking okay one of
them is not looking at the camera this
guy right here what's he looking at BTK
no he was the the serial killer haha
oops oh letters BAE this is BTS yeah
course they're definitely hot boys tell
you that much
[Music]
I don't know if she's a singer that is
the 100 event using my detective skills
here I don't know I have no idea
I know this is Camila cabeza that you
say her last name yeah she left one
direction no hard feelings
oh she's got songs I know her name I've
just never seen her face
what's a fifth harmony song I would do I
would guess it these are DJs these are
DJs from Finland I'm gonna say that
there are popular on some apps like
snapchat are these guys is this two
different people are the same person are
they twins these guys are probably named
Jack and Bob and they probably have a
channel Cod job even if I did know who
they were I'd probably actively try to
avoid knowing too much about them cuz
twins can kill each other with their
minds and I don't know I'm not
comfortable with that Dolan twins would
they have been successful had they not
been twins I wonder the same thing about
Mary Kay and naturally I guess I feel
old that is that what you want me to say
a woman all else fails they're probably
Viners
[Music]